Julia Roberts  Julia Roberts did something the other  day  that I I have to focus on because no one  is really talking about it and it's so  great it's one of the most positive  developments I've seen out of Hollywood  in a long time in large part I think  because it took place outside of  Hollywood  there was a piece in the New York Times  there was a long interview with Julia  Roberts and she stood up for  homemakers Julia Roberts is 54 years old  now  and she addressed her long absence from  rom-coms she said here's the thing if  I'd thought that a script was good  enough I would have done it  but I also had three kids in the last 18  years that raises the bar even more I  have a sense of great pride in being  home with my family and considering  myself a homemaker you go girl I love  this